[Music]
on this Monday night warm weather brings
out crowds and complacency a stern
message from Ontario's premier go get
tested now even Toronto's mayor has been
warned the tongue lashing I got from my
daughter who is a doctor how the
cavalier attitude everybody go get sick
one day could come back to haunt us the
Prime Minister pushes for paid sick
leave for all Canadian workers and how
should Parliament proceed during a
pandemic we must allow Parliament to sit
with its full functions our democracy
depends on it Beijing's looming strict
security law whether Hong Kong likes it
or not it's like driving a truck through
one country to system the call for
countries to stand up to China and the
NHL's playbook for a comeback when where
and how players could get the ice a game
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with signs of what can happen
as public health restrictions are eased
and people get too relaxed because of
some big crowds out in parks on the
weekend and because case numbers are not
dropping fast enough Ontario is now
delaying plans to allow gatherings of
more than five people these scenes
caused a lot of unease among public
health experts thousands of people went
to this popular Toronto park and not
everyone stayed in their bubble and
followed physical distancing rules I'm
disappointed to say the least these are
smart young people that were there like
come on guys give me a break my
recommendation anyone at Trinity
Bellwood why don't you do us all a favor
and go get tested now there are new
rules in Ontario about who can get a
kovat 19 test the premier says anyone
who thinks they need one can now get one
even if they have no symptoms Ontario is
still falling short of meeting its
target of 16,000 tests per day yesterday
for example just over 8,000 people were
tested next door in Quebec testing has
ramped up the premier says it surpassed
its goal of 15,000 tests a day on Friday
Quebec is still recording the highest
daily number of new cases there were 573
new infections there today Manitoba was
one of several provinces that reported
no new cases today but in Ontario the
number of new cases was above 400 for
the fifth day in a row in total more
than 25,000 people in Ontario have
tested positive nearly 65 percent of
those cases are in the Greater Toronto
Area Geoff sample reports on what
officials there are doing to try and get
the situation under control on Toronto's
hottest day of the year one of the
city's most popular parks was mostly
empty a much different picture from the
weekend when thousands packed the park
sparking a national outcry it was like a
rock concert without the band Ontario
health officials urged anyone who was
there Saturday to monitor for symptoms
and avoid at risk groups such as seniors
for 14 days
it's my recommendation anyone at Trinity
Bellwood why don't you do us all a favor
and go get tested now the premier
wouldn't clarify whether his advice
extends to Toronto's Mayor John Tory was
among those photographed at the park his
mask under his chin I'm a human being I
can tell you the tongue lashing I got
from my daughter who is a doctor who
looks after kovat patients was like very
few that I've experienced in my whole
life the city is now considering new
measures such as these large rings
adopted by some American cities to
encourage physical distancing in parks
but frontline physicians say what's more
concerning than a busy park is the big
picture for the fifth straight day
Ontario reported more than 400 new cases
and while some provinces have flattened
their curves Quebec continues to climb
and Ontario has seen its caseload bounce
back when you look at a curve like
what's happening in BC or Alberta that
that is are going to get there and it's
been really tough dr. Chakrabarti notes
that hospitalizations in Ontario are
down and the transmission is largely in
the Toronto area but the province still
isn't tracking exactly where and how if
we had better granular data and we had
data the to tell us he was getting
infected where they're getting infected
who they're in contact with we have a
much better public health approach
Ontario was looking to step up its
surveillance by expanding testing to
those without symptoms but who've had
contact with a confirmed case like this
patient he says he's feeling fine but
his roommate just tested positive so I
wanted to make sure obviously cuz you
know one will go back into work with
those situations right so Ontario
officials are hoping others follow suit
as a result of the recent rise in cases
they're maintaining restrictions on
large gatherings longer than they
planned we'll have to wait to see the
numbers come down first and we should
know in a week or two whether the events
of the weekend contributed to the
caseload Jeff sample Global News Toronto
it's a long weekend in the US and in
some places that means big time party
time
lots of people appeared to take a
vacation from social distancing rules
and didn't bother wearing protective
masks how the pandemic
playing out varies widely from state to
state but the u.s. is nearing the grim
milestone of 100,000 deaths from koban
19 president donald trump was out on the
golf course this weekend he didn't wear
a mask either as Jennifer Johnson
reports the lacs attitudes could lead to
a surge in cases across the u.s.
shocking images of crowded beaches
boardwalks and pool parties millions of
Americans celebrating this holiday
weekend shoulder to shoulder ignoring
social distancing signs in clear sight
like here in Missouri i opening scenes
as the country's kovat 19 death toll
nears 100,000 I believe God's got me I
try to kind of stay away from as many
people as I can
but not today long lines no mass and
little concern at this Texas waterpark
anybody gonna get sick one day I mean
everybody just says life mean you could
die outside in a car wreck health
experts and other Americans feared this
attitude will lead to a new surge in
kovat 19 cases the speech is full of
selfish people who don't care about
anybody else nobody's wearing masks US
President Donald Trump has encouraged
Americans to get out and spend money as
America's economy continues its freefall
he left the White House on this somber
holiday to visit Baltimore's Fort
McHenry a war of 1812 stronghold that
inspired the star-spangled banner
together we will vanquish the virus and
America will rise from this crisis to
new and even greater heights the visit
coming three days after the White House
coronavirus task force named Baltimore
one of three US cities with the highest
rate of new infections it's an election
year and he's trying to get as much
attention as he can
Maryland's Republican governor Larry
Hogan didn't join the president
Baltimore's mayor repeatedly asked him
not to come set an example for a city
still under a stay-at-home order
but the president like so many Americans
couldn't stay home Jennifer Johnson
Global News Washington the Ontario
government is taking aggressive new
steps to try to get control of outbreaks
in some long-term care homes it's
appointed to hospitals to temporarily
take over the management of two
facilities where altogether more than 70
people have died of Kovach 19 officials
say Downsview long-term care in Toronto
and River Glen Haven nursing home in
Sutton Ontario will be managed by the
hospitals for 90 days and that order
could be extended if needed
Quebec premier is recommending people
wear masks when they leave the house and
today commuters in Montreal and Laval
were given free reusable masks the
Quebec government gave montreal and
without six million dollars to buy them
so they could be distributed to people
as they head back to work it's hoped
this will reduce transmission of the
virus on subways and buses the aim is to
hand out 300,000 masks by the end of
June and there are plans to give away as
many as 1.5 million in the months ahead
many Canadians who stay home because
they are sick don't get paid and today
Prime Minister Justin Trudeau says he
will push for all Canadian workers to
get ten days of paid sick leave Trudeau
says his government will work with the
provinces and territories to ensure it
happens nobody should have to choose
between taking a day off work due to
illness or being able to pay their bills
just like nobody should have to choose
between staying home with kovat 19
symptoms are being able to afford rent
or groceries it's something the NDP has
been pushing for in fact the New
Democrats made it a condition of
supporting the liberal plan to extend
the suspension of full sittings of the
House of Commons about 50 MPs were in
their seats today those David akin
explains how Parliament proceeds from
here is a matter of some debate David
Donna the business of the House of
Commons for most of the day was well the
business of the House of Commons how
should our MPs proceed with the business
of government the Conservatives say it's
simple Parliament should resume with all
of its powers and with the regular
schedule of in-person sittings limited
to 50 MPs
the house at any time Parliament must
meet its role in its place
our fundamental this house our elected
legislature is the beating heart of our
system of government one rookie
Conservative MP traveled all the way
from BC to make this passionate plea for
Parliament's return this is important
madam Speaker while we follow safety
protocols we must allow all committees
to sit fully we must allow Parliament to
sit with its full functions our
democracy depends on it thank you madam
Speaker
but other parties have different ideas
the bloc québécois did strike earlier
deals with the governing liberals but
now say the Liberals broke their
promises
this government hasn't been up to the
confidence people had placed into it and
now it begins to show the Liberals want
hybrid sessions in the House of Commons
some MPs in person some via
videoconference these hybrids would
allow more questions to be put to
ministers but opposition MPs would give
up some of their oversight power and the
right to introduce legislation the NDP
will back the liberal plan but there is
a price if the government does not
deliver on paid sick leave for all
Canadians and real supports for
Canadians with disabilities then we will
not be supporting the motion not two
hours after jug meat saying delivered
that ultimatum Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau acknowledged he was ready to
deal we thank the leader the NDP and the
entire NDP caucus for working with us on
this issue now the vote may not be for a
few days but the argument Canada's
political parties are having about
parliamentary procedure could well
result in some real gains for Canadians
permanent paid sick leave and more money
for those with disabilities and if that
happens Chuck meets saying in the NDP
just might rightfully claim the
political credit Donna
David akin in Ottawa thank you we're
watching a number of developments in the
Cova 19 pandemic tonight the World
Health Organization has temporarily
paused a trial of the anti-malarial drug
hydroxychloroquine the trial was to
determine
whether it's effective as a treatment
for Kovac 19 a paper published in the
medical journal the lancet suggested
people taking hydroxychloroquine were at
higher risk of death and heart problems
Japan is lifting its nationwide state of
emergency 50 new cases of kovat 19 were
reported there today and fewer than 2000
people remain in hospital in Japan
India is allowing domestic air travel
again with increased safety measures in
place the country recorded its highest
single day increase in cases for the
fourth consecutive day nearly 7,000 new
infections were reported in India today
and as restaurants in Spain's capital
reopen health officials have revised
that country's death toll lowering it by
nearly 2,000 it's a result of new data
gathering that identified deaths that
were counted twice or wrongly attributed
to Kovach 19 the new death toll in Spain
is just below 27,000 the complex puzzle
nova scotia RCMP are trying to piece
together coming up more court documents
are unsealed in the investigation into a
mass killing plus the rare storm
pummeled Australia
you
we're learning more tonight about the
complex police investigation into the
Nova Scotia mass murders newly unsealed
court documents show the extensive
police work being done work that could
reveal a motive and whether the gunman
had been planning the rampage for some
time Ross Lord explains the documents
reveal some evidence police have found
and other information they're still
pursuing from the port of pick
properties the gunman owned and burnt
down during the rampage investigators
have seized rounds and ammunition boxes
from his clinic in Dartmouth they've
recovered computer equipment and a cell
phone and they've obtained a court order
forcing telecommunications to provide
his phone records also at the clinic
police seized what they called stored
data from two vehicles a Mercedes and a
Ford Taurus police interceptor some
sections of the unsealed documents are
blacked out but elsewhere they are CMP
notes the killing spree covered more
than 50 kilometres and referring to the
in-car entertainment systems they say
the navigation track logs could provide
information whether gabriel traveled
this route prior to april 18th
the RCMP says in-car systems can store
data like text messages and call logs
from cell phones that are synced with
the vehicle some of the gunman's denture
clinic customers spoke highly of him but
a previous batch of police documents
released last week included statements
from people who knew the killer
describing him as abusive paranoid and a
controlling psychopath Ross lore Global
News Halifax
the RCMP have called the killings
completely senseless but some experts
have a different take to find out you
can go to our website Global News CA /
global national ahead scandal in a
pandemic why did Boris Johnson's top
aide violate his own government's
lockdown
you
remnants of a tropical cyclone battered
Western Australia with wild weather as
severe dust storms mixed with heavy rain
it's been called a once in a decade
storm and hit the region with wind gusts
of up to a hundred and thirty kilometres
an hour the storm is easing but it's
left over 60,000 homes without power and
caused widespread property damage we're
just having a bit of an earthquake here
I'm quite add quite a decent shake here
but if you see things moving behind me
The Beehive moves a little more than
much well that's calm in the middle of a
quake New Zealand's Prime Minister
barely flinched when a 5.8 magnitude
earthquake hit near New Zealand's
capital Jacinda our durn was in the
middle of a live TV interview in the
parliament building when it happened
nor we find Ryan I'm not under any
hanging lights I look like I'm in a
structurally sound sound place a close
adviser to the British prime minister
Boris Johnson is being raked over the
coals for floating lockdown rules today
dominick cummings faced the media and
said he doesn't regret driving his wife
and young son 400 kilometers out of
london to his parents property cummings
says he made the journey because there
were no reasonable childcare options in
london if both he and his wife became
seriously ill at the time his wife was
already sick with Kovac 19:00 and he did
become ill during the drive use he broke
the rules has made the public furious
because it looks like the rules don't
apply to the people in charge I don't
think there's one rule for me and one
rule for other people I knew what the
guidance was it talks about exceptional
circumstances with with small children
and I think that in all the
circumstances I behaved reasonably
illegally and cuming says he is staying
put despite calls for his resignation he
has the backing of the Prime Minister
Boris Johnson who says his adviser acted
responsibly legally and with integrity
Hong Kong is on the edge again China
intends to impose a sweeping new
security law that would allow security
forces from mainland China to operate
inside Hong Kong that would be a fir
since Britain handed over the former
colony in 1997 opponents say it's a
direct attempt to limit freedoms and
silence critics and there are calls for
other countries including Canada to
stand up to China Redman Shannon reports
another clean up in Hong Kong a familiar
sight over the past year even as ko wood
19 put protesting on hold for months
demonstrators defied the lockdown on the
weekend to show concern about Beijing's
proposed national security laws the
proposals appear to go far beyond the
extradition plans that sparked last
year's unrest Beijing says these
protests are the very reason for the
proposed laws and do not threaten Hong
Kong's special one country two systems'
status the Hong Kong independent
separate cannot be left unchecked and
the extremists cannot have a free pass
to commit violent terrorist acts the
laws are set to be passed in Beijing
this week the text mentions treason
sedition and subversion but those words
remain open to interpretation our
message to majority of law abiding
citizens and foreign nationals who love
Hong Kong there is absolutely no need to
panic or worry that you may be
unfavorably impacted but critics say the
laws could lead to Chinese security
forces working on Hong Kong streets it's
like driving a truck through one country
system emily lau a longtime democracy
campaigner says the timing is no
surprise with a world distracted by
covert 19 so to them to the leadership
of the party the Communist Party this is
a golden opportunity to try to rush it
through the u.s. is threatening Beijing
with sanctions but Canada is walking a
diplomatic tightrope with two Canadians
currently being held in China we put out
a very strong statement with a number of
our allies of real concern for the
situation in Hong Kong more protests are
expected in Hong Kong
later this week Redman Shannon Global
News London
[Applause]
next getting back on the ice how the NHL
season is planning a rebound
this was the first day people could
reserve a campsite in BC and so many
people were eager to do it the
reservation system crashed the booking
website went down almost as soon as it
opened 50,000 people tried to access the
system at once more than 27,000
reservations were made for the summer by
11:00 a.m. for those lucky enough to get
past the slow load times and repeated
crashes most provincial campgrounds and
recreation sites in BC are set to open
June 1st the NHL is a step closer to
getting games back on the ice to finish
the season the league and the Players
Association are looking at early June
for players to return to their team
facilities physical distancing measures
will be in effect a maximum of six
players will be allowed to practice
together all players and personnel will
be tested 48 hours prior to entering
facilities and then tested twice a week
players must wear face masks when
entering and leaving the facility there
is no firm timeline though on when games
will begin last week the NHL players
Executive Board approved a proposal for
a 2014 playoff format it's exploring
bringing teams to hub cities where
players would live while they play
inside empty arenas and that is global
national for this Monday I'm Donna
Friesen tonight's your Canada is
Edmonton and this family of Canada geese
cupola Gosling's there we'd love to see
your Canada please email it to viewers
at global national dot-com and thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow take care of yourselves bye bye
you
[Music]